مشاهدينا الكرام مستمرون معكم اذا في هذه
التغطيه المستمره مدن عده منها ريفو حلب
شهدت انهيار عشرات المباني جراء الزلزال
العنيف الذي ضرب سوريا وتركيا فجر اليوم
وتمكنت فرق الدفاع المدني من اسعاف عدد من
المصابين بينهم اطفال وتواصل فرق الاغاثه
بكامل طاقتها البحث عن ناجين في ظل ضعف في
الوسائل وقله للكوادر الفنيه اللازمه
عفرين لا يختلف المشهد صور مؤلمه لا تزال
تصل تباعا واخرى لم تصل بعد لكن ما تكشفه
الصور يظهر حجم الماساه ومستوى الجهود
المبذوله للتعامل معها
[موسيقى]
وفي اضنه وهي احدى اكثر المدن التركيه
تضررا من الزلزال تتواصل عمليات انتشال
جثث الضحايا المعركه طويله النفس ايضا
للبحث عن ناجين وسط روكامل مباني المهدمه
ولعل المشهد فيها تاي يلخص الواقع في كثير
من المدن التركيه الاخرى في عشر محافظات
متضرره من هذا الزلزال العنيف اعداد القتل
والجرحى لا تزال في ارتفاع
وتجاوز حتى هذه اللحظه الفن وستمائه
وخمسين قتيلا
كانت اذا هذه نماذج من اقوى المشاهد
المسجله اليوم اما في الوقت الذي احدثكم
فيه فتصلنا هذه الصور من غازي عنتاب في
ختام يوم طويل بسبب الزلزال المدمر الذي
ضرب اجزاء واسعه من تركيا وسوريا السباق
قائم بين جهود الاغاثه والتحديات الجمه
التي تواجهها
اما هذه الصور فتصلنا من ريف حلب الاوضاع
الصعبه للغايه وفرق الانقاذ تواصل عملها
لاسعاف المصابين وبحثا عن ناجين
وفي ريف ادلب عدد ضحايا الزلزال في تزايد
ودفاع المدني يحذر من النقص في الامكانيات
ويناشد دول العالم الاسراع في تقديم
المساعدات
[موسيقى]
وفي مواضيع الحصاد لهذه الليله
نحو 1800 قتيل والاف الجرحى في اعنف زلزال
يضرب تركيا منذ حوالي قرن
انقره تعلن وقوع اكثر من 150 هز ارتداديه
وانهيار الاف المباني واداره الكوارث تحذر
من استمرار النشاط الزلزالي من منطقه
كهرمان مارش
في شمال سوريا وغربها 1300 قتيل جراء
الزلزال منظمات الاغاثه تعلن المدن
والبلدات المتضرره مناطق منكوبه وتناشد
العالم الاسراع بتقديم المساعدات
وزير الصحه التركيه يتحدث عن صعوبات
لاغاثه المنكوبين
والامم المتحده تتوقع ان يؤدي الزلزال الى
تعطيل عمليات الاغاثه في شمال غرب سوريا
تقول ان الاف الاطفال في خطر
مع رفع تركيا حاله الانذار الى مستوى
يتطلب مساعده دوليه بلدان عده تبدا ارسال
فرق للاغاثه والمساعده وتسيير جسور جويه
لتسريع عمليه الاغاثه
زلزال مدمر هذا اقل ما يمكن ان يوصف به ما
استيقظت عليه فجر الاثنين محافظات جنوبي
وشرقي تركيا والمحافظات الشماليه والغربيه
من سوريا اعداد القتلى والمصابين تتصاعد
بمرور الدقائق والتحديات تزداد كل ما وقفت
فرق الاغاثه على هول الكارثه وجسامه
المهمه التي تنتظرها
اعلنت وكاله اداره الكوارث والطوارئ
التركيه ارتفاع عدد قتل الزلازل الى
1762 والمصابين الى 12 الفا وثمانيه وستين
وقالت السلطات التركيه ان هناك صعوبات
تواجه عمليات اغاثه المنكوبين واشارت الى
تضرر شبكات الكهرباء والغاز في بعض
المناطق بسبب الزلزال واعلن الرئيس التركي
رجب طيب اردوغان الحداد العام لمده سبعه
ايام عقب الزلزال الذي ضرب ولايات بالشرق
التركيه اليوم
[موسيقى]
وفي سوريا ارتفع عدد ضحايا الزلزال الذي
ضرب محافظات حلب وادلب واللاذقيه وحمااء
وطرطوس الى نحو 1300 قتيل والاف المصابين
وكانت الحكومه التابعه للمعارضه السوريه
قد اعلنت ان شمال غربي سوريا اصبح منطقه
منكوبه وناشد مدير الدفاع المدني في شمال
سوريا العالم الاسراع بتقديم المساعدات
كيف تنتهي الحياه في لحظه كيف تبيد
الاشياء في ثوان بدل فجر الكابوسي لزلزال
تركيا وسوريا مخبرا حيا للاسئله الكبرى
عندما ارتجت الارض وارتجفت اوصالها لتفيق
البشريه على جدران تهوي بالساكنين وهم
نيام فتقذف بهم من احلام الكره الى فزع
اليقظه وكان فزعا عظيما هرع الناس الى
الشوارع هائمين في البرد لا يدرون ما
يفعلونه ولا اين يذهبون يمر الوقت يزيد
عدد الضحايا وتختلط الجثث بصراخ المحتجزين
تحت الانقاض وتساؤلات القلق المميت عن
مفقود هنا وجريح هناك وقريب كان في منزل
صار كومه حجاره
والزلازل شبح صامت لكارثه متخفيه مباغته
صاعقه كان قدر اجزاء كبيره من تركيا ان
تكون على صدوعها الزلزال الاول بقوه سبعه
وسبعه اعشار درجه على مقياس ريختر وقع
قرابه الرابعه ونصف فجرا بتوقيت تركيا
وتبعته ارتدادات هي زلازل صغيره اسقطت ما
كان متصدعا من ابنيه ووسمت وجوه الناس
بالرعب وهم يدعون الى اللجوء لمناطق
مفتوحه تركز الزلزال في جنوب شرق تركيا
تحديدا في كهرمان مراش وشمل محافظات
ومناطق واسعه اهمها غازي عنتاب وديار بكر
واورفا وعثمانيه وملاطيا وعبر بقوه الى
سوريا فيما صداه الارضي يمتد مئات
الكيلومترات فشعر به سكان لبنان وقبرص
والعراق ودول اخرى اما شمال سوريا في
المناطق القريبه الحدود التركيه خصوصا في
ادلب وحلب فكانت حصته موازيه للماساه
التركيه هنا في مدن القهر السوري الطويل
يعرف اهلها شكل الدمار وطعم الخوف لكنه
ياخذ كل مره طعمه المر الاول مباني سكنيه
مقتظه واحياء في مدن ضمت نازحين ومتعبين
ومعذبين سقطت وتدمرت وزاد في الماساه غياب
اجهزه انقاذ كافيه او خطه عمل لتوصيل
المساعدات واهمها الخيام وسط عاصفه ثلجيه
لينتقل السوري الضحيه من خيمه الى خيمه
ومن ركام الى ركام ومن تهجير الى تهجير
لقد بدا زلزال تركيا المخيف هزه لعالم
افاق على مشهد الفناء فتسارعت الدول الى
عرض وتقديم المساعده وبلغ عددها بحسب
الرئيس التركي خمسا واربع الدوله فضلا عن
الامم المتحده وحلف النيتو لبرهه ظهرت
البشريه يدا واحده في وجه الكارثه فالتقت
اوكرانيا وروسيا في عرض العون ومثلها
الصين والولايات المتحده مشهد وليد الم
بخاطره امل اليس اجدر بالانسانيه ان
تتكاتف في وجه النوائب والمصائب وفي الكون
منها ما يكفي بدل ان تزيدها بالحروب
والصراعات وساحات القتل والسلاح
زلزال تركيا وسوريا وضع العالم كله امام
اختبار تامل في معنى الوجود وجدوى التناحر
والتباغض ان هي الا لحظه من يوم انهيار
الا ومضه من زمن فهل من متعظ
الى جوله مع مراسلين معنا من تركيا تحديدا
من اضنه مراسل الجزيره المعتز بالله حسن
ومن غازي عنتاب مراسل الجزيره منتصر ابو
نبوت وفي شمال سوريا معنى من اعزاز في ريف
حلب مراسل الجزيره محمد الجزائري ومن ريف
ادلب مراسم الجزيره صهيب الخلف مرحبا بكم
جميعا سنبدا من اضنا معك المعتز بالله حسن
كيف يتطور المشهد حيث انت
مازال هناك حاله انتظار هنا في مدينه اضنه
في هذا النقطه على الاقل في محاوله لانقاذ
من يمكن انقاذهم ما زال المنقذون هنا لم
يفقدوا الامل بالوصول الى ناتجنا تحت
الانقاذ على الرغم من مضيء اكثر من 17
ساعه منذ انهيار هذا المبنى هذا واحد من
عده مباني في مدينه اضنه انهارت جراء
الزلزال وايضا هناك بناءان اخران انهارا
نتيجه الهزات الارتداديه هنا ما زالت
المحاوله ربما تشد هذه الشاحنه الالتي
وصلت الان لازاله الانقاض المنظر ولكن ما
زال عمال الانقاذ هناك في الاعلى يحاولون
الوصول الى ناجين يحاولون التواصل او
النداء ليروا ان كان هناك احد مازال
موجودا الاهالي هنا في حاله انتظار وترقب
بحسب الاهالي هنا هناك العشرات الذين
كانوا في هذا المبنى الوضع هو وضع ما في
جميع المدن التي ضربها الزلزال فجر هذا
اليوم منتصر ابو نبوت ماذا عن جهود
الاغاثه ومحاوله انقاذ من هم عالقين تحت
الانقاذ في غازي عنتاب
كما قال زميل المعتز بان الوضع ماساوي في
جميع المدن ومنها مدينه غازي عنتاب ولا
يختلف الحال كثيرا قبل قليل توقفت فرق
الانقاذ هنا عن استخدام الجرافات والاليات
الثقيله في عمليه البحث وعادت للبحث
بالادوات الخفيفه وهذا على ما يبدو يعني
بشير بوجود ناجين على قيد الحياه يعد يسعى
هؤلاء لانقاذ يبدون ان يتعرضوا رئاسه اكثر
من الاذى الذي هم فيه فهم يعني اكثر من 17
ساعه وقد انهار هذا المبنى وهم تحت
الانقاذ وتحاول سيره الانقاذ يعني اخراج
الضحايا طبعا اخرجت عددا منهم طوال هذا
اليوم لكن الامر ليس سهلا في ظل العمل في
ظروف الصعبه وفي درجات الحراره
المتدنيه التي تشهدها مدينه غازي عنتاب
خصوصا انها شهدت تساقط الثلوج قبل ايام من
هذا الزلزال ايضا هذا الموقع هو واحد من
عده مواقع في في وسط مدينه غازي عنتاب
تعمل فرق الانكار على محاوله
يعني انقاذ الضحايا من تحت الانقاذ
ومحاوله يعني مساعده الاهالي الاهالي
الذين تركوا منازلهم هذه جميعها الان هذه
جميعها لا يوجد فيها اي احد لان المبنى
سقط بالقرب منهم وايضا الاهالي الذين في
الاحياء الاخرى التي يعني شهدت الزلزال
لكنها لم يسقط عندها مباني وانما تصدع
ايضا غادروا كل هذه المناطق وذهبوا الى
مناطق مفتوحه الى مناطق مثل الحدائق
والساحات العامه وذلك لانهم لا يريدون ان
يكونوا في مناطق قريبه من اغنياء في حاله
لو ان كان هناك ارتدادات لهذا الزلزال
وهذا يعني انهم سيواجهون معاناه البرد في
هذا الجو المتدني خصوصا ان يعني درجات
الحراره هي ماذون الصفر كما ذكرت وان هناك
مصاعد في عمليه التدفئه نحن
هنا تقريبا منذ الصباح في هذه المنطقه وفي
مناطق اخرى قريبه من هنا ونعاني ايضا كما
يعاني الناس من هذا البرد ومن
الزلزال الذي يدرك ومن الارتدادات التي
تستمر بين الفتره الاخرى الى اعزائي في
حلب محمد الجزائري ماذا عن الوضع هناك في
ظل يعني ضعف الامكانات لدى الجانب السوري
امكانات الاغاثه والمساعده
نعم انسي في الحقيقه مع مضيء الوقت تضع
تضاءل فرص النجاه من تحت الانقاض
للمفقودين
بسبب
بسبب هذا الزلزال بسبب الانهيارات
والابنيه التي دمرت بشكل كبير في مناطق
عديده ايضا هناك عامل نقص الامكانيات لدى
الدفاع فرق الدفاع المدني والنقص
المعدات اللوجستيه هو يزيد بضعف
ضعف فرص النجاه من تحت الانقاض الاهالي
وذوي المفقودين ينتظرون في محيط هذه
الابنيه ينتظرون سماع النات او اصوات
ذويهم لمعرفه ان كانوا على قيد الحياه او
توفوا حاله الهلع لم تتوقف في الشمال
السوري الاهالي يلجاون الى سيارتهم في
الساحات المفتوحه او الى المساجد او الى
الحدائق رغم الب ورغم المطر الشديد في هذه
المنطقه خوفا من الهزات الارتداديه وخوفا
من زلزال اخر ربما
تنتشر اخباره على على وسائل التواصل
الاجتماعي الاهالي الذين فقدوا منازلهم
ودمرت منازلهم وتصدعت يلجاون الى خيام
بناها متطوعون في مدينه عفرين وعزاز وعده
مناطق اخرى في ساحه عامه يؤمنوا يؤمنون
التدفئه وما امكن من مواد غذائيه
ليستقبلوا فيها الناجين والذين فقدوا
ماواهم وفقدوا المنازل جراء هذا الزلزال
والجراء هذا الدمار الكبير فرق الدفاع
المدني تستمر في العمل رغم الصعوبات تقوم
العناصر يقومون بالاستراحه لبضع دقائق ومن
ثم يعودون العمل بهذا الجو بهذا البرد
الشديد وتحت المطر ورغم كل الامكانيات
الضعيفه في منطقه جنديرس التي
تضررت بشكل اكبر في المنطقه هناك ايضا
تضررت البناء التحتيه من شبكه الكهرباء
وقطعت الاتصالات عن المنطقه وباتا من
الصعب الوصول ومعرفه الاخبار اول باول عن
تلك المنطقه بسبب هذه الدمار في البناء
التحتيه ربما الوضع لا يختلف ايضا في ريف
ادلب حيث صهيب الخلف اليس كذلك
نعم ما تزال الفرق الدفاع المدني تحاول
انتشال العالقين تحت الانقاض قبل قليل قال
متطوعون من الدفاع المدني في هذا الموقع
انهم سمعوا اصوات طفلين في زاويه هذا
البناء المدمر وانهم ما زالوا يحاولون منذ
ساعه وحتى الان فتح منفذ في خاصره هذا
المبنى للدخول الى داخل البناء المدمر في
محاوله للوصول الى الطفلين في عمليه
يصفونها بانها حذره ومعقده لكي لا تؤدي
عمليات الحفر الى سقوط
الطبقات البيتونيه فوق الاطفال
وتودي بحياتهما لذلك فان هذه العمليات
تتوقع عناصر الدفاع المدني ان تاخذ وقتا
طويلا وفيما وفيما يخص عمليات الاستجابه
للمشردين جراء تصدع بيوتهم او الذين نجوا
من الدمار فان طلائع هذه المساعدات كانت
في مدينه ادلب على شكل بناء خيم ضخمه
لاستقباء مزوده طبعا بوسائل تدفئه
وتقوم عليها منظمات انسانيه ويقومون
باستقبال هؤلاء المشردين وحتى يتم بعد ذلك
توزيعهم على مراكز ايواء دائمه هذا الامر
طبعا يزيد من من يزيد المتاعب على كاهل
المنظمات الانسانيه التي تعبت كثيرا مع
النازحين الذين يفوق عددهم مليون وثمانم
في شمال غربي سوريا
اشكركم جوله مراسلينا من ريف ادلب مراسل
الجزيره صهيب الخلف من اعزاز في ريف حلب
محمد الجزائري من غازي عنتاب منتصر ابو
نبوت ومن اضنه المعتز بالله حسن
قال الامين العام للامم المتحده
في المناطق المتضرره من الزلزال في تركيا
وسوريا وان فرقا من المنظمه تعمل على
الارض لتقييم الاحتياجات وتقديم المساعده
للمتضررين
تقوم الامم المتحده بالتعبئه لدعم
الاستجابه للطوارئ لذا دعونا نعمل معا في
تضامن لمساعده جميع المتضررين من هذه
الكارثه والذين كان العديد منهم بالفعل في
امس الحاجه الى المساعده الانسانيه خلال
فتره عملك مفوض للاجئين
ذهبت عده مرات الى هذه المنطقه ولن انسى
ابدا الكرم غير العادي الذي اظهره سكان
المنطقه فيما يتعلق باللاجئين الفارينه من
احد اصعب النزاعات في عصرنا لقد حان الوقت
الان لنا جميعا لاظهار التضامن مع سكان
المنطقه
من جهه ثانيه اعلنت الامم المتحده نشر فرق
تابعه لها لتقييم الكوارث والتنسيق لدعم
الاستجابه للزلزال بناء على طلب من تركيا
وقالت ان هناك اكثر من 700 من موظفيها في
المناطق المتضرره من الزلزال وتوقعت ان
يؤدي الزلزال الى تعطيل عمليات الاغاثه في
شمال غرب سوريا من جهتها قالت اليونيسف ان
الاف الاطفال في خطر بعد الزل الزلازل
المدمره التي ضربت تركيا وسوريا وادت الى
تشريد الاف العائلات مشيره الى ان اوضاع
الاطفال في ظل البرد باتت اكثر خطوره وقال
مكتب الامم المتحده للشؤون الانسانيه انه
تم تسجيل اعداد كبيره من المفقودين جراء
الزلزال
معنا من مقر الامم المتحده في نيويورك
فرحان حق نائب المتحدث باسم الامين العام
للامم المتحده مرحبا بك سيد فرحان هل
تمكنت فرق الامم المتحده من احداث تقييم
اولي لابرز الاحتياجات لاسيما على صعيد
مساعده فرق الانقاذ من اجل
الاسراع في انقاذ الارواح
نحن بدانا في الامم المتحده ان نقوم
بتقييم بالاحتياجات لقد بدانا
محاولين ان نقرر ما هي الاحتياجات في
في جنوب تركيا وفي شمال غرب سوريا
بالتاكيد هذا الاحتياجات ستكون كبيره حتى
قبل هذه الهزه الارضيه فان الامم المتحده
وشركاءها نحاول نساعده
ما يصل الى 1.7 مليون شخص في شمالي سوريا
وبالتاكيد هذه المساعدات وهذا الرقم
سيزداد والحاجه والامكانيه لمساعده
الاشخاص ستكون اصعب بسبب الطرق المدمره
والممرات وامور اخرى بالتالي نحن بدانا
بتقييما للاحتياجات قد يتطلب الامر عده
ايام لاكتمال هذا التقييم وايضا نقوم في
نفس الوقت
اعاده
توزيعي وتعيين الاحتياجات الموجوده مثلا
المواد الغذائيه التي تكون اساسيه للناس
التي يحتاجونها لكن
بالاخذ بنظر الاعتبار حجم الدمار والناس
الذين اصبحوا بدون ماوى فان الحاجه ستكون
هائله ونحتاج نعمل ان المجتمع الدولي
سيكون مهيا لمساعده الناس في تركيا وفي
سوريا في موضوع سوريا تحديدا سيد فرحان
لان سوريا تعاني من ضعف كبير في البنيه
التحتيه ومن اثار حرب استمرت على مدى
سنوات ما نوع المخاوف او ما هي المخاوف
لدى المسؤولين في المنظمه الدوليه من
تداعيات هذا الزلزال على المجتمع هناك
لدينا الكثير من بواعث القلق حول كيفيه
تمكننا من تقديم المساعده للاشخاص الذين
كانوا بحاجه قبل لهذا الارضيه والان الناس
الذين اصبحوا بعد الهزل الارضيه بدون ماوى
وبدون منازل بالتالي هنالك الكثير من
القضايا المختلفه احدها ان لدينا نقطه
عبور حدوديه في باب الهوى وهذه هي النقطه
التي
ورخص مجلس الامن المرور من خلالها وعلينا
ان نرى ما مدى سهوله
حضور شحنات المساعدات في هذه النقطه
بالنقد بالنظر الاعتبار الضرر الذي لحقه
بالطرقات الطرقات في تلك المنطقه بالتالي
علينا ان نقيم ما هي افضل الطرق لتقديم
المساعده بشكل فعال لمن يحتاجها هناك في
شمال غربي سوريا بالتاكيد الناس الذين
يعانون في منطقته غازي عنتاب في تركيا
هناك يعني يتواجد منظمات تابعه للامم
المتحده تنشط وتعمل هناك هل تستطيع الان
تكييف عملها مع المتطلبات التي
فرضتها او فرضها هذا الزلزال
بالتاكيد نامل ان شركائنا في العمل
الانساني باستطاعتهم ان يساعدوا من نشاطهم
لكن مره اخرى هنالك تحدي فرض علينا انه
ليست نزلت تقديم المساعده لكن
طواقيمنا على الارض هم عانوا انفسهم من
هذه الكارثه لا نعرف اذا ما كان بعضهم بعض
الخسائر في طواقي قم الامم المتحده اعتقد
انه سيكون هنالك بعض منهم من ضمن الخسائر
لكننا نقوم باحصائي افراد طواقمنا في
المنطقه وانا ايضا المنظمات الانسانيه
الموجوده على الارض عليها ان تقوم بنفس
الشيء وعلينا ان نرى ما الذي يمكن ان نقوم
به ما هي اوضاع المخازن
والشاحنات التي تستخدم لنقل
الاغاثه وايضا من الذين يستطيع ان ننقده
الان لكي نستطيع ان نوصل المساعدات من
يحتاجها اشكرك من مقر الامم المتحده في
فرحان حق نائب المتحدث باسم الامين العام
للامم المتحده
في تذكير سريع باهم ما وقع اليوم نبدا من
غازي عنتاب التي رصد لنا مراسلنا فيها عمر
الحوراني اثار الدمار جراء الزلزال
تنقلنا هنا في في هذه الولايه في ولايه
غازي عنتاب وكان هناك عدد من المباني التي
سقطت وكنا نسمع اشخاص
يطلبون المساعده من تحت هذه الابنيه التي
سقطت جراء هذا جراء هذا الزلزال وكما
ذكرنا ان هناك عدد كبير من المباني التي
سقطت جراء الزلزال الذي ضرب جنوبي تركيا
او لاسيما
ولايه غازي عنتاب التي ننقل لكم هذه
الصوره منها لانتشال الضحايا من تحت انقاذ
هذا المبنى عمر الحوراني الجزيره
ولايه غازي عنتاب جنوبي تركيا
مباشره الى انقره وهذا المؤتمر الصحفي
للمتحدث باسم منظمه الاغاثه التركيه من
هناك
اذا انتهى المؤتمر نعود الى الاحداث التي
وقعت اليوم حيث افاد مراسل الجزيره في
سوريا بان عمليات البحث من عالقين تحت
الانقاض ما تزال مستمره في ثلاثه مواقع
تضررت بشكل كبير في محافظه ادلب شمال غرب
سوريا وبحسب الدفاع المدني السوري فان
اعداد المناطق المتضرره من الزلزال بلغت
400 موقع في ريفي ادلب وحلب التفاصيل مع
مراسلنا في ريفي ادلب صهيب الخلف
نحن الان في مدينه حارم قرب الحدود
السوريه التركيه قبل قليل قال متطوع
الدفاع المدني السوري انهم سمعوا صوت
طفلين من داخل البناء المدمر لذلك عملوا
بشكل سريع على فتح نافذه بين الطوابق
الباتونيه وهم يحاولون الدخول الى داخل
البناء المدمر
لانتشال الطفلين يقولون ان ذلك العمل يجب
ان يتم بحذر شديد لان اي خطا يمكن ان يؤدي
بحياتهما لذلك فهم يتوقعون ان يطول العمل
حتى يتمكنوا من الدخول اليهم بامان هنا في
منطقه حارم تم الاستغناء عن الجرافات
الكبيره وحاليا يتم العمل بشكل يدوي طمعا
في الوصول الى ناجين تحت الانقاض فرق
الدفاع المدني ما زالت تعمل في منطقه
الاتارب وكذلك في منطقه بسنيا القريبه من
هنا حيث شهدت المنطقه اضرارا كبيره
صهيب الخلف الجزيره مدينه حارم ريف ادلب
اسطنبول وحيد الدين كيجان مدير العلاقات
الخارجيه في هيئه الاغاثه الانسانيه
التركيه مرحبا بك سيد وحيد الدين كايجان
ما هي ابرز الصعوبات التي
تواجهونها في هيئات الاغاثه في مساعده
الناس على الارض
مساء الخير طبعا اولا يعني
منطقه الكارثه واسعه جدا يعني ليس مدن
عشره مدن في تركيا منطقه واسع جدا وايضا
في شمال سوريا يعني وايضا في هذه الايام
في كل المناطق فيه بروده والثلج والطرق
الكثير من الطرق مغلقه هذه كله المواقع
يعني لا نستطيع ان نصل الى منطقه الزلزال
بسرعه فقط بحمد الله يعني الى الان نحن
وصلنا الى كل مدن وبدانا العمليات البعث
والانقاذ في كل المدن طبعا اوليتنا الان
نركز على البعث والانقاص في هذه المدن
الان الى هذه الاكثر من
1100 شخص في المنطقه في عشر المدن وهذا
خمسه وستين
في اماكن مختلفه مع هذا طبعا نحن ارسلنا
الاغاثه عاجله من المدن مختلفه من اسطنبول
من انقره من قونيا من مدن الغير مدمره او
اخرى وانت تتحدث الينا اريد فقط ان اشير
الى هذا الخبر العاجل على شاشتنا
نقلا عن اداره الكوارث والطوارئ التركيه
تتحدث عن ارتفاع عدد قتل الزلزال في تركيا
الى
2316 قتيلا والمصابين الى ثلاثه عشر
و293
و 93 الف مصاب ينضم الينا ايضا من شمال
ادلب منير مصطفى نائب ومدير الدفاع المدني
السوري في شمال سوريا مرحبا بك سيد منير
تشترك معنا في هذا اللقاء وفي هذا النقاش
سيد منير نسالك ماذا عن ابرز المصاعب
والتحديات التي تواجهها فرق الاغاثه في
شمال سوريا
نعم اهلا وسهلا ومرحبا بكم وفي المشاهدين
جميعا في الحقيقه
الثالثه لم تمر من قبل على
المناطق في شمال غرب سوريا ولا في سوريا
بشكل بشكل او باخر فرق الدفاع المدني منذ
ساعات الصباح الاولى منذ الساعه الرابعه
صباحا من فجر يوم البارحه هي في مناطق
العمل
اطلقت الدفاع المدني
برقيه استنفار كامله لكافه عناصر الخوذ
البيضاء وهم ملتحقون باماكن العمل وايضا
اطلق نداء استغاثه لكل من يستطيع ان يؤازر
الدفاع المدني ويقدم للدفاع المدني بعض
المساعده حتى نستطيع الوصول الى العالقين
تحت الانقراض وهم على المساعده يحتاجها
التي
تحتاجها فرق الدفاع المدني
في الحقيقه يوجد عند الدفاع المدني اليات
ومعدات هي كفيله ان يقوم بمثل هذه الاعمال
ورفع الانقراض وسحب العقيم من تحت الانقاض
ولكن بحجم عمليه الانقاذ التي تحصل الان
نحن نتكلم عن ما يعادل 400 موقع في نفس
اللحظه هو بحاجه الى مداخله لعمليات البحث
والانقاذ فهو بحاجه الى اليات اكثر في
بحاجه الى معدات نجد رفع الانقاض وسحب
العلاقين من تحت الانقاذ وهذه المعدات
التي يملكها الدفاع المديه هي غير كافيه
هل استطاع ان يعمل ان يقوم باستنفار كامل
لكافه الاطهم ولكافه العناصر
يصل يعني عدد التوعيه الخوذ البيضاء
تقريبا حتى 3000 متطوع الجميع حاليا هم في
العمل من منذ الساعه الرابعه من فجر يوم
البارحه ولكن هذا لا يكفي للاسف لان مواقع
العمل هي كثيره
بعض مواقع العمل تحتاج لبعض الاليات
الاختصاصيه التي تساهم بحذف او باخر تساهم
با الضحايا بشكل كبير فهذا هو الجانب
الضعف الموجود الذي ناشد الدفاع المدني
الدول وناشد من يقدم له المساعده بهذا
الامر انت تعرفين في مثل هذه الكوارث
الطبيعيه حتى في الدول المستقره هي دائما
تنادي وتناشر الدول الاخرى حتى تقدم لها
المساعده حتى تستطيع ان تصل باسرع وقت
ممكن
ان ترفع الانقراض وتسحب العالقين وهم على
قيد الحياه اي ساعه او اي تاخير او اي
دقيقه راح يكون فيها تاخير هذا يعني ان
الروح وهنا السؤال يعني ان انسان ممكن
وهنا السؤال يعني معظم من يعملون في مجال
الاغاثه يتحدثون عن سباق مع الوقت سيد
وحيد الدين كيجان هنا السؤال متى تصبح
الامور حساسه نحن نتحدث اليك لم تمر 24
ساعه بعد على وقوع هذا الزلزال ولكن في
حال مرور 24 ساعه متى يمكن ان تصبح الامور
حساسه جدا بالنسبه للعالقين تحديدا تحت
الانقاض
يعني يعني والدتنا
82 ساعه يعني ثلاثه ايام الاول الى يوم
الثالث نحن نركز على هذه الاعمال البعث
والانقاذ لان عندنا الخبره يعني من قبل
نحن وصلنا الى الاحياء تحت الانقاذ
في يوم الثالث يعني بعد
اثنين سبعين ساعه لاجل هذا اولا الان نركز
على هذا فقط المنطقه واسعه
والدماغ كبير جدا يعني العدد المبنى
كبير جدا اكثر من 6000 المبنى وفي كل
المبنى فيه عائلات يعني
مبنى ممكن تشرين عائله او فوق هذا يجي هذا
هذا الان يعني في كل المنطقه الان نركز
على هذا فكل المتطوع وكل الذي عنده تدريب
البحث والانقاذ كل المتطوعين نحن الان
ارسلنا الى المنطقه
كثير منهم واصلوا اكثر من 18 وصلوا
والباقي ان شاء الله سيصلون في الساعات
القريبه في هذه الساعات لان في المدن
مختلفه شيء ثاني الطرق فيها بعض المشاكل
لان كل واحد الان يريد يذهب الى عائلاتهم
الى اقاربهم هذا ايضا الان يكون في بعض
المشاكل فقط الاعمال نركز على هذا وقسم
الثاني الذي يعني هم نجوا من الانقاذ لابد
الان نركز عليهم بالباطانيات
الشوربه الساخنه من الاكل ساخنه نحن الان
بدانا ان ارسلنا الى المنطقه
المطابق المنتقده الى
منطقه مختلفه وان شاء الله بدانا في
الغازي عنتاب في مالاتيا وفي
القضيه مان في بدانا توزيع
الطعام الساخن وان شاء الله في قهرمان وفي
المدن الاخرى ان شاء الله في اقرب الوقت
يعني في هذه الليله ان شاء الله اخوها
يبداون الان في كل المدن الحمد لله وصلنا
مع الجمعيات التركيه مع الجمعيات الحكوميه
والغير حكوميه كل تركيا الان يعني في حاله
الطوارئ وكلهم وصلوا كثير من الذي خاصت
عندهم خبره عنده تثبيت تدريب البحث سيد
منير مصطفى وصلوا سيد منير مصطفى ماذا
ايضا عن المشردين يعني نحن راينا في شمال
سوريا قرى باكملها سويت بالارض من جراء
هذا الزلزال ماذا عن من نجى ولكن لم يعد
لديه ماوى
في الحقيقه هي معاناه اخرى تضاف الى
معاناه التي نتجت عن الزلزال الذي حدث في
شمال غرب سوريا هناك تضافر جهود من
المنظمات المحليه العامله في هذه المنطقه
من اجل بناء بعض المخيمات الطارئه
التي تنشا بشكل سريع ويقدم فيها بعض
الحاجيات الاساسيه من اجل عمليات التدفئه
وهي تكون من القماش فهي هي هي اماكن امنه
تكون بديله عن البيوت المتصدعه وعن البيوت
المتهدمه للمدنيين اليسما يتم حل المشاكل
العالقه في هذه البيوت وسحب العالقين من
تحت الانقاذ وفتح
الطرقات واعاده يعني ترميم هذه البيوت
المتصدعه لان صراحه العوده الى هذه البيوت
متصدعه هي خطيره جدا فنتوجه نحن المنظمات
الاخرى طبعا نضع يدا بيد باتجاه نؤمن
مساكن سريعه من خلال هذه المخيمات لتكون
هي ماوى في هذا الشتاء الذي يضيف دائما
معاناه للاسف على المعاناه الناتجه
البدائل سيد منير يعني المنطقه اصلا تعاني
من ازمه ازمه لاجئين وكنا نتحدث في الايام
الماضيه عن معانات هؤلاء اللاجئين في
الخيام ومخيمات
النزوح بسبب الطقس البارد ماذا حصل يعني
هل تفاقمت هذه المشكله نفهم منك
صحيح تفاقمت وبشده هذه المشكله ونحن نتوجه
باتجاه المخيمات التي لا تكون هي قادره
على ان تقي الحر وتقي البرد ولكن هي في
هذه المرحله صراحه تقي الموت يعني الذي لم
يمت تحت الانقاذ انهيار
المباني صراحه هو سيموت من البرد جراء
البرد القارس نحن نعرف انها هي عباره عن
حل اسعافي لا بديل له للاسف في هذه الحلقه
الاوقات ولكنه حل ضروري اجواء هذه العوائل
لاواء الاطفال النساء الرجال الذين هم
باتوا
يومهم الكامل في العراء وسيبتون هذه
الليله ايضا في الاعراب فكان لا بد من
تقديم شيء حتى نستطيع ان نلقي هؤلاء
الاشخاص من برد هذا الشتاء الحمد لله منذ
الصباح حتى الان لم تتوقف هطول الامطار
وفي بعض الاماكن كان هناك تساقط لبعض
الثلوج وهذا كان يضيف دائما معاناه فوق
المعاناه سيد وحيد الدين كيجان الان هناك
استجابه دوليه من اكثر من نحو 45 دوله كما
قال الرئيس التركي
لهذه هذا النداء التركي بالمساعده في ظل
اثار الزلزال ما المطلوب الان من كل هذه
الدول الى ما انتم بحاجه وبحاجه ماسه
وبسرعه
يعني طبعا اولا كما قلت يعني اول اوليتنا
واول الان
البعث والانقاذ يعني الذي عنده خبره البعث
والانقاذ اولا الان عاجلا نحتاج كل تركيا
يحتاج هذا والشيء الثاني تابعنا الاغاثه
العاجله يعني الان كثير من مدن كله الشعوب
الان في خارج لا احد يقتل البيوت
البارد والشتاء في هذه الايام يعني اشد
بروده في هذه الشتاء والثلج يعني
لابد ان نحمي الذي
نجوا من هذه الزلزال نجد تحت الانقاص نحمي
هذه للاطفال والنساء والشيوخ لاجل هذا
يعني الان المنطقه يحتاج كل
يعني كل شيء من الدعم كل شيء من المساعدات
اي مساعده الان يصل الى منطقه الان
يحتاجون طبعا هذه اليوم الاول لابد الان
ان شاء الله في هذه الليله يعني لا لا
يحدث ان شاء الله غدا
سيحسن الامور شويه لان الان بداوا اعمال
المساعدات في كل المدن وكل يعني كل الشعب
التركي الان في حاله الطوارئ والذي عنده
خبره
ذهب الى المنطقه والذي لم يستطيع يذهب
الان بدا يجمع المساعدات ان يكون باي شيء
طبعا كل الجمعيات من خارج او كل الدول
الذي ياتي يعني الان المنطقه يحتاج كل
انواع المساعدات طبعا كما قلت البحث
والانقاص في مهم هذا جدا
ليؤمن يعني
يومين قبل ان منير مصطفى في ادلب ماذا عن
ما يتطلبه الوضع في شمال سوريا ايضا من
مساعده من المجتمع الدولي يعني نحن نعرف
المشكله الان هناك عقوبات على سوريا هناك
حصار هناك مشاكل سياسيه تترافق مع كل ما
يجري كيف يجب الان على المجتمع الدولي ان
يتعامل مع ما يحدث في سوريا في ظل ضعف
الامكانات
والظروف المعروفه
صحيح بالاضافه لما تكلمت له هو كافه
الميزان الاولى الكفه الاخرى هناك حاله
انسانيه صعبه جدا كارثه طبيعيه هي صعبه
جدا لم تمر على سوريا ولا على المجتمع
السوري من قبل ولكن يجب عن على دول العالم
ان تتوجه باتجاه التعامل مع هذه الكارثه
باتجاه المحاوله ايصال هذه المساعدات
لشمال غرب سوريا وللاسف ليس هناك فريق الا
من عبر عبر تركيا وتركيا هي ايضا متضرره
جراء هذا الزلزال البنيه التحتيه متضرره
هناك ايضا ضرر كبير وخاصه على المناطق
الحدوديه التي هي تكون متاخمه لمنطقه شمال
الغرب سوريا هناك اضرار يعني لحقت بها
بشكل كبير طبعا عزاءنا اكيد للشعب التركي
ولذوي الضحايا الاتراك ولذوي الضحايا ايضا
السوريين ولكن هو واقع صعب ومرير يجب ان
يتعامل معه الدول على ما هو
بحالته الانسانيه وليس على ما يترتب عليه
من عقوبات سياسيه ومن من منع دخول مثلا
الاموال باتجاه الداخل السوريا وضع انساني
مزري يجب ان تكون هناك حاله طوارئ تستثنى
بعض الامور تستثنى بعض العقوبات لادخال
المساعدات الى نجد لنجد هذا الشعب المجتمع
السوري بالكامل وايصال المساعدات الى
الداخل السوري شكرا لك منير مصطفى نائب
ومدير الدفاع المدني السوري في شمال سوريا
من شمال ادلب وشكرا وحيد الدين كايجان
مدير العلاقات الخارجيه في هيئه الاغاثه
الانسانيه التركيه ضيفنا من اسطنبول
في ردود الفعل الدوليه قال الرئيس
الامريكي جو بايدن انه يشعر بحزن عميق
بسبب الخسائر في الارواح والدمار نتيجه
الزلزال في تركيا وسوريا وذكر البيت
الابيض انه يعتزم ارسال مزيدا من الفرق
تتضمن 279 فردا لمساعده تركيا في اعمال
البحث والانقاذ اما مسؤول العلاقات
الخارجيه في الاتحاد الاوروبي فقد اعلن ان
عشرا من دول الاتحاد تقدم مساعدات
للمشاركه في عمليات الانقاذ منها بلغاريا
ورومانيا وهولندا وفرنسا واعربت روسيا عن
استعدادها لتقديم مساعدات وقد اتصل الرئيس
بوتين بالرئيس السوري بشار الاسد وبعث
رساله تعزيه للرئيس التركي رجب طيب
اردوغان واعلنت الخارجيه القطريه انطلاق
اولى رحلات الجسر الجوي الذي خصصته قطر
الى تركيا لدعمها في مواجهه كارثه الزلزال
كما كانت وزاره الاعلام الكويتيه عن تسيير
جسر جوي الى تركيا لتقديم مساعدات واطقم
طبيه عاجله واعربت ايران عن استعدادها
لمساعده الضحايا في كل من تركيا وسوريا
واعلنت عزمها ارسال سيتي فرق انقاذ الى
تركيا لتقديم المساعده في عمليات الامداد
وتنسيقها واعلنت بريطانيا عن استعدادها
لتقديم مساعدات فوريه لتركيا ومزيدا من
الدعم للخوازات البيضاء في سوريا وقالت
اليابان انها سترسل فريقا مكونا من 75
فردا للمساهمه في عمليات الانقاذ
في التقرير التالي نستعرض تفاصيل زلزال
كهرمان مارش والمناطق التي ضربها في تركيا
وسوريا وما خلفه من ضحايا واضرار وصفت
بالكارثيه وغير المسبوق
تتحرك شرائح التكتونيه في طبقات الارض
باعماق مختلفه محدثه الزلازل والهزات
الارتداديه جنوبيه تركيا في ولايه كهرمان
مراش عند الساعه الرابعه والنصف صباحا
بالتوقيت المحلي تحركت الشرائح التكتونيه
على عمق 18 كيلو مترا متسببه بزلزال شديد
بلغت قوته 7 درجات وسبعه اعشار الدرجه على
مقياس ريختر فكان هذا المشهد
طرف الزلزال معظم الولايات الجنوبيه من
تركيا وهي شانلي اورفا ديار بكر ومالطيه
وايضا مان وغازي عنتاب وكلس وعثمانيه
وهاتاي واضنه موقعا الاف الضحايا بين قتلى
ومصابين تسبب بانهيار الاف الابنيه وضرر
كبير في الطرقات وانقطاع خدمات الكهرباء
والاتصال والمياه في كثير من المناطق التي
ضربها زلزاء ساعات قليله يحدث زلزال ثاني
قرب كهرمان مراش وصلت قوته وفقا لمركز
ابحاث الزلازل التركيه الى سبع درجات وسته
اعشار الدرجه على مقياس الخطر زاد من
اضرار سابقه وضحاياه قالت اداره الكوارث
والطوارئ التركيه ان اكثر من 120 هزه
ارتداديه وقعت في محيط مركز الزلازل وهي
بحسب وصف الرئيس التركي رجب طيب اردوغان
اكبر كارثه تشهدها البلاد منذ عام 1939
الزلزال وصلت اثاره الى سوريا فضرب
محافظات حلب وادلب وحماو اللاذقيه وطرطوس
وصولا الى دمشق التي شعر سكانها بهزه
ارضيه وفق وكاله سانا الرسميه هنا ايضا
خلف الزلزال الاف الضحايا بين قتلى
ومصابين وفق ما اوردته الجهات الرسميه في
مناطق وجود المعارضه شمالا ومناطق النظام
السوري
في سوريا تستمر اعمال البحث بامكانات اقل
لكن حصيره الضحايا سواء في سوريا او تركيا
ستبقى مرشحه للارتفاع
[موسيقى]
ينضم الينا من عمان الدكتور نجيب ابو كركي
استاذو الجيوفيزياء وعلم الزلازل في
الجامعه الاردنيه مرحبا بك دكتور نجيب ابو
كركي بالنظر الى ان هذه المنطقه حيث وقع
الزلزال اليوم تشهد نشاطا زلزاليا قديما
منذ القدم هل كيف يمكن تقييم الزلزال الذي
جرى اليوم نظرا الى قوته
وتداعياته واثاره
نعم يعني هو زلزال تقريبا اقصى ما يمكن ان
يحصل في تلك المنطقه بالذات في تركيا وهو
زلزال كبير بكل المقاييس
منذ القدم يعني في الواقع منذ ملايين
السنين وتتكرر هذا هذا النوع من الزلازل
في تركيا 70 رئيسيين كبيرين اللي هم صدع
شمال الاناضول وصدع شرق الاناضول وهذا
مرتبط يعني اكثر في الجزء الجنوبي من
تركيا الزلزال كبير بكل المقاييس حصل مثله
في الواقع في التاريخ
1138 وهكذا يعني يؤثر على نفس المناطق
عمليا لاثر عليها في هذه المره ايضا
يعني اليوم ترافق هذا الحدث مع جدل كبير
حول ما اذا كان بالامكان توقع حدوث
الزلازل مسبقا ام لا هل لديك جواب على هذا
الامر
لا يوجد دقه في موضوع التوقع حتى يحصل على
مساله انه تنبؤ يعني لا يمكن تحديد اللحظه
اللي راح يحصل فيها هذا الزلزال لا يمكن
تحديد برضه قوته بشكل دقيق يمكن تقييم كل
هذا من المعلومات التاريخيه ومن السياق
التكتوني اللي بيكون في المنطقه يعني
معروف مثلا انه تركيا وايران
والقوقاز هي التي يحصل بها اعنف انواع
الزلازل على الحدود الصفيحه العربيه لانه
في الواقع هي المناطق التصادم في ما بين
الصفائح في على تلك الصدوع ومناطق تصادم
معروف بانها يعني تعطي اعنف انواع الزلازل
واكثرها ترددا وفترات زمنيه قصيره ما بين
كل زلزال والثاني تركيا يعني لا يمر بضعه
سنوات بها الا ويحصل فيها كارثه كبيره
للاسف من هذا النوع اقل قليلا او اكثر
قليلا بشكل نادر جدا 1939 قدرات قيمه
المقدار الزلزالي بثمن وثمان درجات اكبر
بكثير من سبعه وثمانيه بالعشره لكن في
الواقع في نوع من ايضا عدم الدقه في موضوع
تحديد القوى قد يكون هنالك كسور يعني فروق
ما بين تقدير وتقدير اخر والزلازل رئيس
مركز رصد الزلازل في تركيا اليوم تحدث عن
رصد حوالي
134 هز ارضيه نتيجه هذا الزلزال ويتحدث عن
ان تردداته ستستمر وقد تتواصل حتى عام من
الان ماذا يعني كل ذلك دكتور
يعني اننا نتوقع هزات ارتداديه حتى يعود
الوضع يعني الى نوع من انواع التوازن في
المنطقه وهذا قد يستمر اسابيع الى اشهر
الى سنه او اكثر انما بالنمط العام
للزلازل هي مع الزمن تقل وتقل قواها يعني
حتى يعود الوضع الى ما كان عمليا عليه
الوضع السابقا اما بالنسبه للرقم الزلازل
فلا يوجد معنى كبير لهذا في الواقع
بالتاكيد يجب ان يكون هذا مرتبط باعتبارا
من ايه قوه يعني انا اعتقد بانه ازمه
زلزاليه من هذا النوع
لو سجلنا الزلازل الكبيره والصغيره فيها
فسنحصل على عشرات الالاف من الزلازل في
هذا اليوم وليس فقط 164 لكن 164 او ما
شابه ذلك تعني انه فوق من خمس وطالع مثلا
قوه خمسه فما فوق او الزلازل يعتبرها
مؤثره الان هناك مخاوف في المناطق التي
ضربها الزلزال من ان يحدث زلزال اخر زلزال
جديد او ربما ارتداديه جديده تكون قويه
كذلك هل يمكن توقع هذا الامر
في الواقع يعني هذا برضو في السياق
الطبيعي لا يمكن التوقع اللحظه بالذات
ولكن يمكن ان نقول بانه خلال الايام
القادمه ستحصل زلازل من النوع المؤثر يعني
والمؤثر يعني قد يكون خمسه فما فوق خاصه
وانه مؤثر على ماذا مؤثر على ابنيه تهلهلت
بشكل كبير واصابها الضعف فبالتالي هي يعني
تحتاج الى طاقه بسيطه حتى تنهى لهذا يعني
لا ينصح مثلا في المناطق بؤره الزلزال او
مناطق مركز زلزال يعني المبيت في المباني
في الوقت الحاضر في في هذا اليوم يعني انا
بعتقد فكرت قبل قليل من الموضوع بانه يمكن
استغلال حتى البيوت البلاستيكيه افضل
بكثير من السكن في هذه المباني لخطورتها
في الوقت الحاضر نتيجه النشاط الزلزالي
اللي بيحصل فيها في الوقت الحاضر والذي لا
يمكن يعني استثنائه ابدا ولا بل هو يعني
محتمل جدا جدا يعني دكتور نجيب الى متى
يجب اخذ هذا النوع من الحيطه
طبعا عندما يلاحظ تناقص هذه الزلازل
وصولها الى درجات يعني غير مؤثره
مع شويه مخاطره يمكن العوده الى الحياه
الطبيعيه لكن في الواقع يعني هنالك خطوره
في موضوع
العوده الى السكنات في الوقت الحاضر الى
يعني الابنيه
خصوصا في المناطق القريبه من موقع الزلزال
والابنيه التي تاثرت بشكل كبير والتي يوجد
احتماليه كبيره ان يتحرك الصدع فيها بهزات
ارتداديه يعني محسوسه بشكل جيد طيب ايضا
يترافق الحديث مع هذا الزلزال عن مخاوف من
وقوعه تسونامي
ايضا ما امكانات ذلك كيف يمكن دراسه هذا
الامر وتوقف في الواقع
نعم في الواقع يعني بالنسبه للزلزال
الرئيس ما دام لم يحصل تسونامي بعد ساعات
من حصوله هذا في الواقع يعني مستثنى انه
لن يسبب تسونامي لكن في الواقع قد يحصل
هزات ارتداديه في البحر تؤثر على مناطق
ايضا غير متوازنه التسونامي يمكن عمليا
ثلاثه اخطاره بشكل كبير لو كان هنالك يعني
او في الواقع في العالم حاليا ما يسمى
بنظام الانذار المبكر ضد تسونامي ولا هو
يعني عباره عن طوافات بتكون في البحر
طائفه يعني
تقيس الاقمار الاصطناعيه
مزوده بالجي بي اس يعني يحدد موقفها او
تحديد المواقع الشامل يحدد موقعها
وبالتالي عندما يلاحظ ارتفاع فجائي على
جبهه من هذه الطوافات يعرف كم كان الفرق
ما بين المستوى الاول والمستوى الثاني ثم
يمكن ايضا ان يرصد كيف تسير هذه الموجه
ولا اي اتجاه وبالتالي اعطاء الانذار
هنالك اوقات يعني هنالك ربما يعني ساعات
او عشرات الدقائق من الممكن للمناطق
الساحليه حسب قرفه او بعدها من موقع بدايه
حصول تسونامي تسونامي يعني يسير بسرعه
تشابه سرعه الطائره النفاثه الف كيلو متر
في الساعه عمليا في عرض البحر على عمق
حوالي 7000 متر اذا كان البحر بهذا الشكل
وعندما نصل الى 200 متر بالقرب من الشاطئ
بيكون السرعه تقريبا حوالي 200 كيلو متر
في الساعه في الواقع يعني من يرى تسوناني
قادما حب قليل
في الجامعه الاردنيه ضيفنا من عمان شكرا
جزيلا لك
من بيروت ينضم الينا الدكتور حسام
الشرقاوي المدير الاقليمي للاتحاد الدولي
لجمعيات الصليب الاحمر والهلال الاحمر
لمنطقه الشرق الاوسط وشمال افريقيا مرحبا
بك دكتور حسام الشرقاوي كيف تابعت جهود
الاغاثه والمساعده اليوم في كل من تركيا
وسوريا حيث وقعت كارثه الزلزال
اهلا وشكرا على تصميم على هذه الكارثه
الحقيقيه
من الساعات الاولى الصباح اليوم والفرق
كلها تتابع التقييم السريع التقييم
الاحتياجات وادخال المساعدات بالتركيز
خاصه الى سوريا لانه الوضع يختلف بين
سوريا وتركيا تركيا دوله
منظمه قويه
عندها امكانيات واستعداد
معشر سنه
ومقاطعه وعقوبات
واستعدادها ليس نفس المستوى كتركيه
في صعوبه جدا برضه انه نوصل للمناطق
المنكوبه العواصف
المطر
درجه الحراره تحت الصفر
والثلوج الليله
تركيزنا كان اليوم على العمليات الانقاذ
البحث والانقاذ دعم جمعيه الهلال العربي
الاحمر العربي السوري على
البحث والانقاذ بالتعاون مع الدفاع المدني
عندهم والاسعاف الاولي
والتركيز برضو على دعم الفئه المؤممه منحه
البطانيات وخيم وتدفئه ومياه هذا
المرحله الاولى وعدنا عده مراحل طبعا
للدعم حتى تستمر ليست ايام ولا اسابيع
ولكن اشهر نتوقع على الاقل الان هناك جهود
دوليه تبذل من اجل المساعده كيف يمكن
التنسيق بين الاحتياجات على الارض وكل ما
يقدم على الصعيد الدولي
التنسيق مهم جدا
ونتفادى الازدواجيه وان الدول
بكرمها ترسل شغلات
سوريا او تركيا ليس محتاجه لها او محتاجين
امور اخرى ولا لا ترسل فدورنا الاساسي هو
التنسيق وارسال المعلومات الاحتياجات
الاساسيه والاولويه لجميع الدول اللي حبت
تساعد والحق يقال انه كتير من الدول كان
في تكافل
وعروض للدعم بدات الساعات الاولى من صباح
اليوم وحتى تستمر
ودورنا دكتور
الاقليميه الاتحاد الدولي لجمعيات الصليب
الاحمر والهلال الاحمر لمنطقه الشرق
الاوسط والشمال افريقيا حدثنا من بيروت
اشكرك جزيل الشكر على هذه المشاركه معنا
تغطيتنا مستمره مشاهدينا الكرام وهذا
التذكير بابرز العناوين
نحو 1800 قتيل وحوالي
13,300 مصاب في اعنف زلزال يضرب تركيا منذ
نحو قرن انقره تعلن وقوع اكثر من 150 هزا
ارتداديه وانهيار الاف المباني واداره
الكوارث تحذر من استمرار النشاط الزلزالي
من منطقه كهرمان مارش
نحو الف قتيل وثلاثه عشر الف وثلا مصاب في
اعلى في زلزال يضرب تركيا منذ نحو قرن
انقره تعلن وقوع اكثر من 150 هز ارتداديه
وانهيار الاف المباني واداره الكوارث تحذر
من استمرار النشاط الزلزالي في منطقه
كهرمان مارش
وزير الصحه التركي يتحدث عن صعوبات لاغاثه
المنكوبين
والامم المتحده تتوقع ان يؤدي الزلزال الى
تعطيل عمليات الاغاثه في شمال غرب سوريا
واليونيسف تقول ان الاف الاطفال في خطر
مع رفع تركيا حاله الانذار الى مستوى
يتطلب مساعده دوليه بلدان عده تبدا ارسال
فرق للاغاثه والمساعده وتسيير جسور جويه
لتسريع عمليه الاغاثه
[موسيقى]
اعلنت اداره وكاله اداره الكوارث والطوارئ
التركيه ارتفاع عدد قتل الزلازل الى
2316 والمصابين الى
13,293 وقالت السلطات التركيه ان هناك
صعوبات تواجه عمليات اغاثه المنكوبين
واشارت الى تضرر شبكات الكهرباء والغاز في
بعض المناطق بسبب الزلزال واعلنا الرئيس
التركي رجب طيب اردوغان الحداد العام لمده
سبعه ايام عقب الزلزال الذي ضرب ولايات
بالشرق التركي اليوم
وفي سوريا ارتفع عدد الضحايا الزلزال الذي
ضرب محافظاته حلب وادلب واللاذقيه وحماه
وطرطوس الى نحو
1389 و 3000 وخمسمائه وتسعه عشر مصابا
وكانت الحكومه التابعه للمعارضه السوريه
قد اعلنت ان شمال غربي سوريا اصبح منطقه
منكوبه ونشد مدير الدفاع المدني في شمال
سوريا العالم
بتقديم المساعدات
كيف تنتهي الحياه في لحظه كيف تبيد
الاشياء في ثوان بدل الفجر الكابوسي
لزلزال تركيا وسوريا مخبرا حيا للاسئله
الكبرى عندما ارتجت الارض وارتجفت اوصالها
لتفيق البشريه على جدران تهوي بالساكنين
وهم نيام فتقذف بهم من احلام الكره الى
فزع اليقظه وكان فزعا عظيما هرع الناس الى
الشوارع هائمين في البرد لا يدرون ما
يفعلونه ولا اين يذهبون يمر الوقت يزيد
عدد الضحايا وتختلط الجثث بصراخ المحتجزين
تحت الانقاض وتساؤلات القلق المميت عن
مفقود هنا وجريح هناك وقريب كان في منزل
صار كومه حجاره
والزلزل شبح صامت لكارثه متخفيه مباغته
صاعقه كان قدر اجزاء كبيره من تركيا ان
تكون على صدوعها الزلزال الاول بقوه سبعه
وسبعه اعشار درجه على مقياس ريختر وقع
قرابه الرابعه ونصف فجرا بتوقيت تركيا
وتبعته ارتدادات هي زلازل صغيره اسقطت ما
كان متصدعا من ابنيه ووسمت وجوه الناس
بالرعب وهم يدعون الى اللجوء لمناطق
مفتوحه تركز الزلزال في جنوب شرق تركيا
تحديدا في كهرمان مراش وشمل محافظات
ومناطق واسعه اهمها غازي عنتاب وديار بكر
واورفا وعثمانيه وملاطيا وعبر بقوه الى
سوريا فيما صداه الارضي يمتد مئات
الكيلومترات فشعر به سكان لبنان وقبرص
والعراق ودول اخرى اما شمال سوريا في
المناطق القريبه الحدود التركيه خصوصا في
ادلب وحلب فكانت حصته موازيه للماساه
التركيه هنا في مدن القهر السوري الطويل
يعرف اهلها شكل الدمار وطعم الخوف لكنه
ياخذ كل مره طعمه المر الاول مباني سكنيه
مقتظه واحياء في مدن ضمت نازحين ومتعبين
ومعجبين سقطت وتدمرت وزاد في الماساه غياب
اجهزه انقاذ كافيه او خطه عمل لتوصيل
المساعدات واهمها الخيام واستعاصفه ثلجيه
لينتقل السوري الضحيه من خيمه الى خيمه
ومن ركام الى ركام ومن تهجير الى تهجير
لقد بدا زلزال تركيا المخيف هزه لعالم
افاق على مشهد الفناء فتسارعت الدول الى
عرض وتقديم المساعده وبلغ عددها بحسب
الرئيس التركي خمسا واربع الدوله فضلا عن
الامم المتحده وحلف النيتو لبرهه ظهرت
البشريه يدا واحده في وجه الكارثه فالتقت
اوكرانيا وروسيا في عرض العون ومثلها
الصين والولايات المتحده مشهد وليد الم
بخاطره امل اليس اجدر بالانسانيه ان
تتكاتف في وجه النوائب والمصائب وفي الكون
منها ما يكفي بدل ان تزيدها بالحروب
والصراعات وساحات القتل والسلاح
زلزال تركيا وسوريا وضع العالم كله امام
اختبار تامل في معنى الوجود وجدوى التناحر
والتباغض ان هي الا لحظه من يوم انهيار
الا ومضه من زمن فهل من متعظ
الى جوله مراسلين معنا من اعزاز في ريف
حلب مراسل الجزيره محمد الجزائري من غازي
عنتاب مراسم الجزيره منتصر ابو نبوت من
مقر الخارجيه الامريكيه مراسل الجزيره
محمد الاحمد ومن مقر الامم المتحده في
نيويورك مراسل الجزيره مراد هاشم مرحبا
بكم جميعا سنبدا من اعزاز من ريفي حلب مع
محمد الجزائري محمد كيف تتقدم وتتطور جهود
الانقاذ ورفع الانقاذ والاغاثه
في الحقيقه مع كل دقيقه مع كل ساعه تتضاءل
الفرص للنجاه من تحت الانقاض للعالقين
والمفقودين تحت الركام الابنيه التي سقطت
فوق رؤوس قاطينها وذلك بسبب مضيء الوقت
منذ الساعه الرابعه فجرا وحتى الان افرق
الدفاع المدني تعمل في كل المواقع في كل
النقاط التي دمرت فيها ابنيه سكنيه وسقطت
فوق رؤوس قاطنيها جهود كبيره
تبذلها فرق الدفاع المدني من ريف ادلب
وحتى مدينه ادلب والى ريف حلب بالكامل من
مدينه جرابلس حتى جبل الزاويه مناطق شاسعه
تعمل على عليها فرق الدفاع المدني لرفع
الانقاض والبحث عن ناجين المناطق المتضرره
في الشمال السوري هي الاكثر تضررا هي
منطقه حارم وسلقين بالاضافه الى سرمدا
الدانه الاتاري الترمانين ومدينه جنديرس
الاضرار كبيره جدا
العدد الابنياء عشرات الابنيه سقطت فوق
رؤوس قطنها وما زال ما زال الاهالي عالقون
تحتها
الفرق تعمل بالامكانيات المستطاع المتوفره
لديها فرق دفاع مدني ناشدت الاهالي من من
يملكون اليات ثقيله او اليات قد تنفع في
البحث
والرفع الانقاض ان يجربوها الى اقرب نقطه
فيها اضرار وفيها ابنيه
ساقطه فوق رؤوس قاطنيها الاهالي ايضا
يساعدون فرق الدفاع المدني ايضا
الفصائل المعرضة ومسلحه تعمل على مساعده
هذه الفرق للبحث عن ناجين ذوي
المفقودين يتجمهرون في محيط هذه الابنيه
من نساء واطفال ينتظرون سماع اخبار او
معرفه مصير ذويهم تحت الانقاذ هذه المنازل
بالتحديد في مدينه جنديرس شاهدنا مشاهد
مدنيه مشاهد قاسيه جدا النساء تنتظر وتبكي
لمعرفه مصير ابنائها او ذويها اطفال تخرج
من تحت الانقاذ ميته لتسلم لذويها ووالدها
او اهلها مشاهد جدا صعبه مواقف صعبه جدا
يعيشها الاهالي النازحون هنا حاله الاهالي
الذين فقدوا ماواهم او فقدوا منازلهم
وتصدعت منازلهم او دمرت بشكل جزئي نزحوا
ولجاوا الى مدن مثل مدن عفرين واعزاز ومدن
كثيره حتى في وسط مدينه ادلب مدينه ادلب
انشا
نشطون
بعض المنظمات المحليه وبجهود محليه وفرديه
عده خيام لاستقبال اللاجئين والذين دمرت
منازلهم فقدم اواهم في جميع المناطق
يؤمنون في هذه الخيام التدفئه وبعض المواد
الغذائيه
لاستقبالها هؤلاء العدد الكبير من الاهالي
الذين فقدوا منازلهم حتى الان الاهالي في
عموم الشمال السوري اغلبهم لم يعد الى
منازلهم ما زال في الشوارع في سيارات او
في المساجد او في الحدائق ينتظر
هدوء بشكل تام ينتظر توقف الهزات
الارتداديه يتخوفون من زلزال قد يزيد
المعاناه لديهم او يجعلهم كمن سبقهم تحت
الانقاض ليتم البحث عنهم حاله الاجواء
تزيد من المعاناه الاهالي الذين ينتظرون
في الشوارع في الساحات او في الحدائق
حقيقه يعني المشهد يتطور بشكل يعني كبير
يعني قبل قليل كنا في موقع بالقرب من هنا
كان قد
تهدم بسبب الزلزاله الاول وكانت فرق
الانقاذ تعمل في هذا الموقع لكن هزه
ارتداديه كانت قويه وقد شعرنا بها بشكل
كبير جعلتهم يخرجون من الموقع وقالوا ان
هذا المكان اصبح الان خطرا لان المبنى
المهدم قد يعني
يتسبب بمزيد من الضحايا الذين يقفون في
محيطه بالاضافه الى ان المباني القريبه من
هذا المبنى تصدعت عندما سقط هذا المبنى
والان ممكن اي هزه ارتداديه قويه كالتي
يعني جاءت قبل قليل ان تسقط مبنى اخر لذلك
طلبوا منا هذا المكان والخروج منه الى
مكان امن الحقيقه كلمه كان امن هي كلمه
صعبه لكن الاهالي جميعهم يذهبون الى
الساحات العامه والى الحدائق والى
المساجد التي تكون في محيطها ساحات واسعه
لا يوجد بالقرب منها مباني يمكن ان تسقط
عليهم في حال يعني
جاءت هزه ارتداديه قويه نحن الان في احد
هذه الحدائق في مدينه غازي عنتاب كثير من
الاهالي يعني جاؤوا بسياراتهم ووضعوا
اطفالهم ونساهم في هذه السيارات وقاموا
بتشغيل التدفئه لان الجو بارد وانهم لان
في هذه الحديقه مثلا هي تبعد عن المبالغ
في حال يعني حدث زلزال جديد لا سمح الله
فان هؤلاء الاشخاص يمكنهم ان يكونوا بماما
نوعا ما نشاهد هذه هذا الجانب من هذه
السيارات ممكن تحريف الكاميرا لنشاهد هذه
هذه السيارات هنا
تنتشر في هذه المكان وايضا نشاهد الثلج
هذا الثلج يزيد من المعاناه نحن هنا يعني
نتحدث عن درجه حراره ما دون الصفر وهذا
الامر هو الذي زاد من معاناه الاهالي ايضا
هنا سيارات كثيره للاهالي يعني تقف هنا
وعلى ما يبدو ان الجميع لا يريد العوده
الى المنازل خلف هذه السيارات على بعد
يعني خليل هنالك مباني نشاهد هذه المباني
هل احد لا
يريد اصبح خطيرا خصوصا مع الهزات
الارتذاريه التي يعني تاتي باستمرار وهو
ما يعني اثار الذعر والرعب في قلوب
الاهالي وهذا امر منطقي وامر متوقع لكن
عندما نخرج الى هذا المكان نجد ان الدرجات
الحراره البارده تزيد ايضا من المعاناه
ايضا هناك معاناه في تامين بعض المواد
الاساسيه والاغذيه بالنسبه لهم هم الان
سيعيشون في هذا المكان سيعيشون في هذه
السياره فعليهم ان يقوموا بتامين متطلبات
الحياه الاساسيه لحين معرفه مصير او نهايه
هذا الامر الذي يعيشونه منذ اكثر من 20
ساعه طبعا مدينه غازي عنتاب في هذه
اللحظات التي نتحدث فيها معكم هنالك مواقع
ومباني اخرى مهدمه وتامل فرق الانقاذ فيها
سيارات الاسعاف لم تتوقف عن
نقل الضحايا وايضا كل يعني كل عشر دقائق
كل ربع ساعه ان نشاهد سياره اسعاف تذهب
الى المستش المستشفيات الحكوميه
والمستشفيات الخاصه التي فتحت جميعها
جميعها من اجل معالجه الضحايا وايضا يعني
مساعده الاشخاص الذين اصابهم بعض الامراض
بسبب الخوف نتحدث عن خوف من زلزال زلزال
كان مرعبا لم يكن امرا سهلا واله ايضا
كانت قويه في يعني في في غالبها وكنا نشعر
بها بشكل بشكل كبير لذلك نجدهم في اماكن
واسعه جميعهم يكونون بهذه الاماكن الواسعه
بحيث اذا يعني كان هناك هزه ارتداديه قويه
وسقط مبنى فلا يتاثرون بسبب هذا المقاومه
من العوده الى المنازل خوفا من تجدد
الزلزال وايضا خوفا من الهزات الارتداديه
المستمره منتصر ابو نبوت من غازي عنتاب
سانتقل الان الى محمد الاحمد الموجود في
الخارجيه الامريكيه في واشنطن محمد
الولايات المتحده تدعم عبر نشر فرق دعم في
جهود الاغاثه وايضا سجلت مكالمه هاتفيه
بين الرئيس الامريكي ونظيره التركي حول
هذا الزلزال واثاره ماذا في التفاصيل
سيتحدث قريبا الى نظيره التركي رجب طيب
اردوغان علما بان بعض التقارير نقلت عن
الرئاسه التركيه ان الاتصال جرب الفعل
وبالتالي نتوقع بيان مرتقب للبيت الابيض
بشان فحوى هذا الاتصال تزامنا مع ذلك
الخارجيه الامريكيه ذكرت قبل او في
مؤتمرها الصحفي اليوم بان وزير الخارجيه
التركي مولود شاوش
للتعبير عن تعازي وتضامن الولايات المتحده
بعد هذا الزلزال المدمر الذي ضرب تركيا
وسوريا ونتوقع ايضا مزيد من التفاصيل بشان
فحوى هذا الاتصال في بيان مرتقب ايضا
للخارجيه الامريكيه الخارجيه الامريكيه
اشارت الى ان فرق امريكيه ستتولى للبحث
والانقاذ ستتوجه خلال الايام القليله
المقبله الى تركيا علما بان البيت الابيض
والمتحدث باسم مجلس الامن القومي جونكر
الى فريقين امريكيين من المتوقع ان يتوجه
الى تركيا خلال الفتره القليله المقبله
لدعم عمليات البحث والانقاذ الخارجيه
الامريكيه اشارت الى ان قنصليتها في اضنه
على استعداد لاستضافه هذه الفرق شددت على
ضروره بقاء المعابر الانسانيه بين تركيا
وسوريا مفتوحه امام حركه المنظمات
الانسانيه
واشارت في هذا السياق الى انه لن يتم
التعامل باي شكل مع من الاشكال مع النظام
السوري وبان المساعدات الامريكيه ستكون
حصرا عبر المنظمات الانسانيه المدعومه
امريكيا في الاثناء ايضا البينتاجون اشار
الى ان وزير الدفاع تحدث مع نظيره التركي
خلوصي اكار واشار كذلك الى ان الطائرات
العسكريه الامريكيه من المتوقع ان تنقل
فرق الانقاذ الامريكيه تركيا هناك تاكيد
امريكيه على مواصله التنسيق والتواصل مع
الجانب التركي في الفتره المقبله للوقوف
على احتياجات تركيا في هذه المرحله وايضا
التاكيد على الوقوف مع الشعب السوري
طبعا من اجل تقديم المساعدات الانسانيه في
هذه المرحله علما بان الولايات المتحده
تعد اكبر مانح انساني للشعب السوري في
الاثناء ايضا لا توجد اي معلومات او
تاكيدات بشان ضحايا امريكيين عقب هذا في
تركيا عقب هذا الزلزال المدمر كان هناك
ايضا تعابير مواساه وتضامن من اعضاء كبار
في الكونغرس الامريكي ونتوقع ال سي بكل
تاكيد مزيد من التواصل والتنسيق بين
الولايات المتحده وتركيا في المرحله
المقبله مرادها في الامم المتحده قبل قليل
كان معنا نائب المتحدث باسم الامين العام
للامم المتحده فرحان حق الذي توقع صعوبات
في جهود مساعده
المتضررين ماذا ايضا في التفاصيل وفي
توقعات الامم المتحده بالنسبه لكيفيه
مقاربه هذه الجهود
بالفعل ال سي وايضا كما توقع وتوقع ايضا
متحدثون اخرون باسم الامم المتحده صعوبات
حتى في عمليه تقييم الخسائر الناجمه عن
هذه الزلازل هناك الفرق التابعه للامم
المتحده ووكالات الاغاثه التابعه لها تضم
اكثر من 700 700 من العناصر والموظفين في
كل من تركيا وشمال سوريا ولكن هناك صعوبات
ناشيه عن الاضرار التي
نجمت عن هذه الزلازل بما في ذلك انقطاع
الاتصالات انقطاع الكهرباء انقطاع الطرق
بل والتضرر منشات بعض المنشات لهذه
الوكالات ذاتها ما يعني ان انه حتى
المساعدات الاعتياديه التي كانت تقوم بها
هذه الوكالات سوف تتعثر لفتره
الامم المتحده تتوقع ان
تنتهي من عمليه التقييم هذه في غضون يوم
الى عده ايام وهي تبني على هذا التقييم
الكثير من الامور بما في ذلك تقدير حجم
الخسائر وبالتالي تقدير حجم الاموال
المطلوبه
للاغاثه والمساعده ومصادر هذه الاموال قد
يكون بعضها من الصندوق المركزي لحاله
الطوارئ التابعه للامم المتحده لكن
بالتاكيد ستحتاج الامم المتحده كما اشار
المتحدث باسم الامين العام الى اموال
اضافيه ولا سيمه مع النقص السائد في
الاموال المخصصه لخطه الاستجابه الانسانيه
في سوريا بطبيعه الحال هناك التزام من
الامم المتحده
بالقيام
بالمساعده والدعم ولكن كما اشار الامين
العام هناك حاجه الى دعم مالي دولي ال سي
شكرا لك من مقر الامم المتحده مراسلنا
مراد هاشم شكرا لمراسلنا محمد الاحمد من
مقر الخارجيه الامريكيه في واشنطن شكرا
لمنتصر ابو نبوت مراسلنا من غازي عنتاب
ولمراسلنا محمد الجزائري من اعزاز في ريف
ادلب
واعذرونا على الاطاله عليكم في هذا الطقس
البارد شكرا جزيلا لكما
لتقريب الصوره اكثر فيما يتعلق بولايه
كهرمان مارش جنوبي تركيا والتي كانت مركز
الزلزال زار مراسل الجزيره عامر حلبي
المنطقه المنكوبه ووقف على حجم الدمار
فيها
نحن الان في ناحيه بازار في ولايه كرمان
مراش جنوبيه تركيا هنا كان مركز الزلزال
الذي ضرب جنوبيه تركيا وسوريا هنا دمار
كبير لحق بهذه المدينه منذ وصولنا اليها
شاهدنا عشرات المباني المدمره اما بشكل
كامل او بشكل جزئي المباني التي لم تظهر
عليها اثار الدمار هي متصدعه من الداخل
وغدا كثير منها غير صالح للسكنه الان هذا
المبنى المؤلف من سته الطوابق انهار بشكل
كامل على ساكنه وهنالك
الان فرق الانقاذ تعمل وتبحث عن المفقودين
تحت الانقاض قبل قليل كانوا يتواصلون مع
اشخاص ومع وائل باكملها موجوده تحت
الانقاض وهم على قيد الحياه والان يعملون
من اجل انقاذهم ومن اجل انتشارهم في
المقابل تم استخراج ايضا العديد من الجثث
ممن نقي من الاشخاص الذين لقوا حتفهم بعد
انهارت هذا البناء
اليهم وكذلك في مباني اخرى ايضا يوجد
العديد من الضحايا وايضا العالقين تحت
الانقاض لكن لا ارقام دقيقه عن اعداد
الضحايا في هذه المنطقه نظرا لان الدمار
كبير ولان عمليات البحث عن المفقودين ما
تزالوا مستمره تشاهدون المدنيين الاهالي
ممن تضررت منازلهم واصبحوا في الشارع
اصبحوا بلا ماوى التقينا وتحدثنا الى عدد
منهم واخبرونا بان وضع مدينتهم قد اصبح
ماساويا بعد ان حل هذا الدمار الكبير
بمدينتهم وبعد ان خسروا وفقدوا العديد من
ذويهم وياملون بان تتمكن فرق الانقاذ من
اسعاف ومن انتشال العديد من الاشخاص من
تحت الانقاض
عمرو حلبي الجزيره من ناحيه بازارك ولايه
الكرمه مرعش
ومن مدينه حارم في ريف ادلب شماليه سوريا
رصد لنا مراسل الجزيره صهيب الخلف اثار
الدمار جراء الزلزال
لا معلومات دقيقه عن عدد الناس الذين
كانوا يسكنون في هذه المباني لكن امامنا
اربع مباني يتالف الواحد منها نحو ارض من
اربعه طوابق وهذه المدينه بشكل عام مكتظه
بالسكان لان النازحين من جميع انحاء سوريا
يقصدونها وهي قريبه من الحدود السوريه
التركيه لذلك يتوقع ان تكون ان يكون عدد
الضحايا كبيره كبيره في الحقيقه في المدن
المدن التي تضررت هي المدن التي تقع بجوار
الحدود السوريه التركيه وكل هذه المدن
مكتظه بالسكان لا يمكن ان تجد مثلا منزلا
فارغا ليس فيه عائله تسكنه لان هذه المدن
اصلا تستوعب اكثر من طاقتها بكثير
المناطق التي تضررت قلت المناطق القريبه
من الحدود السوريه التركيه مكتظه بالسكان
وكما ان مناطق سيطرت النظام السوري ايضا
طالها بعد طالها الكثير من
الدمار والكثير من الاضرار وزاره الصحه
التابعه النظام تعلن عن اكثر من 200 قتيل
هناك محافظه حماه انهار بناء من تسع طوابق
وايضا اسفر عن قتلى وجرحى محافظ حماه تبعد
عن هذه النقطه 130 كيلو متر وبالتالي فان
اثار الهزات الارضيه وصل الى 133 كيلو متر
اثناء سيرنا في خط
الاتجاه الحدود السوريه التركيه مررنا على
عده بلدات كانت هناك خسائر لكن كل بلده
وخسائر بسيطه لكن كل بلده مررنا فيها كان
فيها بناء دمره او مبنى طابقي دمره نحن
نتحدث هنا عن اقتضاء السكان سكاني وتغير
ديموغرافي كبير والمدن هنا حدثت فيها يعني
طفره عمرانيه باتجاه
استيعاب النازحين الذين ياتون وبالتالي
فان هذه المدن فان هذه المباني ليست مجهزه
بشكل جيد النازحون يسكنون حتى
التي كانت قد تعرضت للقصف او المباني
للسقوط
والتركيبه السكانيه هنا حقيقه هي
استثنائيه بكل ما تعني الكلمه وبالتالي
فان مثل هذه مثل هذه الكارثه التي حدثت
بالتاكيد سوف يكون لها مضاعفات كبيره على
السكان
وقد رصد مراسل الجزيره في سوريا الوضع في
مدينه جندريس بريف حلب حيث تهدمت عشرات
المباني فوق ساكنها جراء الزلزال
نحن الان في مدينه جنديرس في ريفي عفرين
كما نشاهد هنا الصوره خلفنا تتكلم هذه
الابنيه التي تدمرت بسبب الزلزال الذي وقع
سفجره اليوم عدد كبير من الابنيه كما
نشاهدها هنا وهذا البناء ايضا هناك فرق
الدفاع المدني تعمل في عده مواقع هنا في
مدينه
واستنفرت كافه
عناصرها ولكن هذه العناصر من الدفاع
المدني لا تكفي ولا ولا تغطي كل المناطق
فما هنا نشاهد عناصر من فصائل المعارضه
تساعد الاهالي بالاضافه الى ان الاهالي
ايضا تعمل على
انقاذ والبحث عن جين تحت هذا الدمار مدينه
جنديرسيه الاكثر تضررا في منطقه ريف حلب
وبالاضافه الى مدينه الاتارب حتى الان لا
يوجد احصائيات واضحه جدا هناك الى الان
عدد كبير بحسب افاده الينا الاهالي عدد
كبير من الاهالي تحت الانقاض وهو ما يرجح
ارتفاع عدد الضحايا هذه الابنيه التي
مقتطفه بالسكان بحسب ما قال لنا الاهالي
وهي كثيره داخل هذا هذا هذه الاحياء حتى
اننا نقف على هذا الردم دمار الابنيه
اضرار كبيره لحقت بالمنطقه هنا نشاهد ايضا
يقومون
بانتشال الضحايا وجمعها
الى المشافي اضرار كبيره وفرق دفاع مدني
تعجز عن
تغطيه كافه هذه الاضرار بالاضافه الى ان
الامطار تزيد من معاناه الاهالي وتزيد من
صعوبه الموقف بشكل كبير محمد جزائري
الجزيره ريفو حلب
لتركيا تاريخ طويل مع الزلازل وبعضا منها
كان مدمرا خلف وراءه اعدادا مرتفعه من
القتلى والمصابين اضافه الى خسائر فادحه
في الممتلكات العامه والخاصه وقفه مع ذلك
في هذا التقرير للزميل نبيل الريحاني
ارض حباها الله بكثير من جمال الطبيعه
وتنوعها وابتلاها بين حين واخر بزلازل لم
تنسى الذاكره التركيه
في هذه المره جاء الزلزال عظيما في مداه
الجغرافي فقد ضرب عددا من المدن وثقيلا في
كلفته الانسانيه اذ تجاوز عداد الضحايا
الالف ومنذ الساعات الاولى للكارثه في
تعداد مرشح ليرتفع ويرتفع معه عدد الجرحى
ستحتاج تركيا الى كثير من الجهد والمال
والوقت لتستوعب المحنه الطبيعيه ومثله بل
اكثر منه على الارجح لتتجاوز اثارها
الكارثيه كارثه تعيد الى الاذان نسخا
قديمه منها في ذاكره لا تكتفي باستعاده
العقود من السنوات بل والقرون كذلك بالامس
القريب وبالضبط في شهر نوفمبر من عام 2020
ضرب زلزال بقوه 6.6 ولايه ازمير التركيه
مخلفا بحسب اداره الكوارث التركيه ازيد من
120 وفيات قبل هذا الزلزال كان هناك اخر
في منطقه بحر ايجا ضرب مدينه بودروم في
العام
وقبل عام من ذلك ضرب زلزال اخر ولايه وان
بشده تجاوزت 7 درجات يقول اهل الاختصاص ان
تركيا ارض الزلازل بامتياز اذ ان السجلات
العلميه تثبت انها تتعرض ما بين كل ست
وسبع سنوات لزلزال يمكن لدرجاته ان تتجاوز
السبع تتصدر منطقه بحر ايجا قائمه المناطق
المهدده بالزلازل فقد تعرضت في المئه عام
الماضيه الى ما لا يقل عن 23 زلزالا مدمرا
واذا ما اوغلنا في التاريخ الطبيعي لتركيا
سنجده يحدثنا عما عرف بزلزال القيامه
الصغرى عام
1509 ذلك الذي ضرب بحر مرمره وتسبب في
دمار كبير لمدينه اسطنبول ولا يسعى ذلك
التاريخ تجاهل زلزال
1719 الذي ضرب نفس المدينه على نطاق شاسع
وقاس تماما كما فعل الزلزالان اخران في
1766 و
عديده هي تلك المحطات المؤلمه بما تخلفه
من خسائر في الارواح والممتلكات الا ان
زلزالي جولجوك ودوجا اخذ في عام
1999 مكانه مفجعه في ذلك الاول جد في شهر
اغسطس وادى الى مقتل ما يزيد عن 17 الف
شخص اضافه الى قرابه 120 الف مصاب في حين
وقع الثاني في شهر نوفمبر والبلاد لم
تستفق بعد من صدمه ووطاه سابقه مخلفا
قرابه الف قتيل وقرابه 700 الف مصاب اما
الخسائر الماديه في هذا وذاك فحدث ولا حرج
تقول انقره انها خبرت مثل هذه الكوارث
واعدت لها وكاله متخصصه هي الان تكافح
لجعل فاتوره تلك الزلازل اقل فداحه بيد ان
الخروج من هذا النسق العالي لتواتر
الزلازل باخف الاضرار يحتاج ثوره عمرانيه
في بلاد تجمع بين المباهات بالمنجزات
الحديثه والحفاظ على ميراث مدن كثير منها
وجهه سياحيه جزء مهم من مبانيها يفتقد اخر
الصيحات الهندسيه في التعامل مع مفاجات
الارض كلما زلزلت زلزالها وانتبه العالم
ليقولا ما لها
من اسطنبول معنا امرا قايا مسؤول العلاقات
الخارجيه بهيئه الاغاثه الانسانيه مرحبا
بك سيد امراكايا ما المطلوب الان وبسرعه
المطلوب طبعا هناك خاصه
لوصول
الطواقم
والباحث ان هناك لان تحت الانقاص هناك
كثير من الناس ينتظرون اخراجها من
بين
المباني لانه هناك كما انتم تعرفون
يتاثر من هذه الزلزال
عشر مدن واحاطتها كبيره جدا
وهناك يوجد كثير الدول بدا
صله
الانقاذ والبحر الى تركيا وهذا شيء مهم
جدا وطبعا هناك كثير من الناس
في الشوارع
بدا ان يبنى لهم مناطق اللجوء
وطبعا هذا مهمه لان نحن الان في صدد موسم
الشتاء وهذه الايام يحاس من اشد البرت
وبتاثير الزلزال هناك كثير من الناس
يحتاجون
الدعم والمساعده
ما زالت الهزات الارتداديه مستمره بين
الحين والاخر هذا الامر كيف يؤثر على جهود
الانقاذ جهودي
رفع الالقاب من اجل انقاذ الناس العالقين
بينها
نعم هذا من مع الاسف السلبيات الكبيره جدا
يعني حتى اليوم نحن شاهدنا ربما من تاريخ
الزلزال عندما لاحظنا الزلزالات القديمه
اول مره نحن لاحظنا متتاليه
بدرجه 7.7
وايضا
بعد الظهر اظن ايضا نحن وجدنا هناك
الزلزال سبعه فاصله سته وهذا من تاريخ
الزلزال من الاقليات جدا وطبعا هناك
وايضا عندما عندما صارت او حدثت اي هزه
ارتدائيه ليس خمسه ثواني يعني على الاقل
بين 15 ثواني او عشرين ثواني يستمر وهذا
طبعا يؤثر
على الشعب وايضا ومع ذلك على التواقم
متواجده في الميدان
ايضا حاله الطرق
المتضرره جدا والمقتظه جدا كيف تؤثر على
امكانات الوصول الى المناطق التي طالها
هذا الزلزال
طبعا هناك يوجد طرق
المغايره ومع ذلك
نحن نواجه
النزول الثلوج وهذا ايضا يؤثر ومع ذلك
الان اغلبيه المدن
الطرقات ممكن نحن نجدها ولكن اهم المشكله
ايصال
بسرعه
السيارات العمل والانقاذ هذا هو من صعوبات
ايضا المتواجده هناك ومع ذلك
الجندي التركي الجيش التركي الان في
الميدان وهم يحاولون وايضا
الافات كل المؤسسات
هناك يوجد تنسيق كبير ولا عالي
ربما نحن نقول 25 الف شخص الان في الميدان
ويحاول ان يلبي احتياجات الناس طيب قبل
قليل كنا نشاهد رساله مراسلنا من غازي
عنتاب راينا كيف ان معظم الناجين خرجوا من
منازلهم يخافون من العوده مجددا للمبيت في
المنازل
اذا عفوا انا مضطره لان اقاطع هذه
المقابله ونذهب مباشره الى هذا المؤتمر
الصحفي لنائب الرئيس التركي في انقره
[موسيقى]
في مدينه نوردا
والمدن التابعه والضواحي
هناك فرق انقاذ من الخارج
وستلتحق بهذه الفرق فغدا سنوافيكم
بالارقام القطعيه
في العثمانيه في مدينه العثمانيه وفي مرعش
ايضا ادى الى هذه النقطه ايضا فرق من
اذربيجان ومن لبنان
وفي
الضواحي ايضا في افشين
والبستان
[موسيقى]
جريتور ايضا
وطبعا القرى والضواحي كلها يتم طبعا
الوصول اليها من خلال المتطوعين
طبعا
الانقاذ منتشره في كل هذه
الضواحف يتم التنسيق مع المركز في المدن
ووفقا لهذه طبعا التوجيهات لفرقه الايقاظ
تتوجه للكره والضواحي
هنا ايضا بالنسبه للرافعات لدينا بعض
الاشكاليات تموء وصلنا بعض الشكوى حول هذا
الموضوع
الحفارات
والناقلات
يتم الان توزيعها بالتساوي على المدن
والضواحي وطبعا هناك ايضا
سته رافعات من بورصه وايضا مثل وايضا عشره
رافعات من قيصري
وبذلك يكون العدد 18 رافعه يتم تم ارسالها
الى المنطقه كما ايضا الطائرات مثل ما
قلنا في المؤتمرات السابقه تقوم باسعاف
المنكوبين
ونقل الجرحى للمشافه
بالنسبه
للاقامه
طبعا
هناك
طبعا بعض
[موسيقى]
اشخاص الذين تلقوا الدعم والمساعدات
حول
الخيام
والمعدات المطبخ
والبطانيات
نحن نقوم بتوجيه
المساعدات لهؤلاء الناس طبعا بالنسبه
لمراكز الاقامه ليس فقط الخيام بل ايضا
قلنا في المؤتمرات السابقه ان ايضا السكن
الطلاب والفنادق
والمضافات
جميعها مفتوحه
المنكوبين الان
شخص يستفيدون من المضافات التابعه
لوزاره التعليم
وايضا
في الجامعات
والمضافات التابعه
عفوا اريد ان اجدد
رقم وزاره التعليم
هناك تحديث
دائما يطرا على هذه الارقام
من
الاشخاص المعكوبين
الان يقتلون مراكز الرياضه والملاعب
[موسيقى]
من طرف اخر بالنسبه للغذاء الهلال الاحمر
يلعب دورا
[موسيقى]
مهمه في هذه العمليه ايضا
ادارات المحليه
والولايات في المدن
يقومون بالتنسيق عمليه توزيع الغذاء
والطعام الساخن
على المنكوبين وحتى الان الهلال الاحمر
وايضا وزاره التعليم
تقوم بتوزيع الغذاء
مرش في
مرعشين والبستان وانطاكيا
يتم توزيع
الطعام على المنكوبين
الهلال الاحمر
[موسيقى]
بالفعاليات التوزيع
الطعام الساخن والشوربه على المنكوبين
وسيواصل دعمه لهذه الفئه من الناس
[موسيقى]
اريد ان ازودكم ببعض التفاصيل
طبعا الكهرباء والانقطاع يؤثر على عمليه
التدفئه على عمليه التواصل والاتصال
بعد المؤتمر الذي عقدناه سته موزعات
للكهرباء
الان خارجه عن
العمل
وباقي
الموزعات نقاط التوزيع
التواصل
فعالياتها
وهناك ايضا
الموزعات المتنقله التي يتم الان نقلها
الى هذه المنطقه في بحلول الاربعاء
والخميس والجمعه
سيتم الوصول الى هذه المنطقه
تم ايصال الكهرباء الى قهر
الريحانيه الان فقط منتصف او نصف
الريحانيه تصل يصلها الكهرباء
ايضا
[موسيقى]
ننتظر تاييد اداره الكهرباء بان ايصال
الخط الكهربائي ليس خطرا
لكي نفتح تيار الكهربائي
هذه المحافظه
في مدينه العثمانيه
ايضا سيتم
[موسيقى]
الفحص
الشبكه اذا كانت لن تؤثر على عمليه
الانقاذ
وسيتم فتح التيارات الكهربائي
ايضا يتم وصل الكهرباء بشكل تدريجي ومتقطع
ين من عمليه واصل الكهرباء لجميع قرى
وضواحي
كهرمان مراش ايضا في قضيه مان
الان بدا ايصال الكهرباء لضواحي في الغاز
الطبيعي
انطاكيا ومرعش
كما قلنا في المؤتمر
السابق ان هناك بعض الانقطاع في التيارات
التي شبكه ايصال الغاز الطبيعي
[موسيقى]
والان تجري عمليه اصلاح الانابيب
ليتم تفعيل هذه الشبكه
بحلول الاربعاء ان شاء الله
سنتمكن من وصل الغاز الطبيعي بالشبكه
طبعا
صيانه الشبكات مهم جدا
وقبل ان تصلوا
الغاز الطبيعي ولكن والا لا سمح الله ممكن
ان تتسببوا
لاكارثه جديده اذا لم تحذروا هذا الموضوع
[موسيقى]
وان شاء الله بعد عمليه
الصيانه
نوزع الطاقه
موضوع
الاتصال
وايضا موضوع مولدات الكهرباء
سيتم طبعا توزيع
[موسيقى]
الوالدات الى المدن المنكوبه والتي بحاجه
الى
الكهرباء
ايضا بالنسبه للوقود سيتم ايصاله الى هذه
المناطق الوقود
الذي يستخدم في عمليه توليد الكهرباء
بالنسبه للاتصالات
طبعا الموضوع متعلق
لا اله الا الله
والانقطاع الكهربائي مثل ما قلنا عندما
ينقطع الكهرباء
[موسيقى]
لشبكات الجي اس ام طبعا لا يتم تفعيل
الشبكه
ولكن
[موسيقى]
نقطه توزيع تم ايضا ارسال مولدات طاقه لها
لكي تعمل بمعزل عن الشبكه الكهرباء العامه
ونحن نريد ان نحل هذه
المساله قبل طبعا ان
[موسيقى]
يحل طبعا السعه الصباح ايضا
خارج المنطقه ايضا لدينا اشكاليه في
الوصول الى المنطقه لان هناك
هطول
او تساقط للثلوج وغزاره في العواصف
الثلجيه
والطرقات مسدوده
وطبعا هي تحول دون وتؤخر
وصول
المساعدات الى هذه المنطقه
ويتم تنظيف الثلج عن هذه الطرقات ولكن
الثلوج والعواصف تغلق
الطرقات سرعان ما تقوم بذلك
ساوافيكم
بكل التفاصيل
ايضا في المنطقه
ايضا
يتم التواصل مع الشركات توزيع الغاز
وفي المناطق التي لا يوجد فيها الغاز
الطبيعي يتم ايضا توزيع المدافئ
ايضا بالنسبه
[موسيقى]
الاشخاص الذين
يعني ليس لديهم اقارب من الافضل ان يتركوا
المدن
ويخرجوها ايضا في الغد
سنقوم بعمليه اجلاء ونشرف عليها
ممكن ان نصدر في الغد اي محافظه ستذهب الى
اي
محافظه اخرى لتستضيف اهلها
في كلس
مثلا في الغد
سنتحدث مثل ما قلنا عن المدن التي
ستستضيفهم
[موسيقى]
بنسبه للمشافي في مشفى انطاكيا
اسكندرون
مارش هناك
اضرار لحقت بالمشافي
ايضا
هذه كله ما لديه ما لدي من معلومات
الموضوع الاخير الذي اريد ان اقوله وهو
لا تصدقوا للحسابات
التي تنشر المعلومات الكاذبه والمغلوطه
فقد ممكن ان تعتمدوا على المعلومات التي
تصدر عن الوزارات وعن افاد الرسميه
والحسابات الرسميه لهذه المؤسسات
اشكركم على حسن الاستماع مره اخرى
اقول للجميع سلامتكم والدوله
والرئيس
قبل ان اتي الى هنا قد تحدثت اليه دائما
نبلغه
بالتطورات
اذا كان هذا جانبا من المؤتمر الصحفي
لنائب الرئيس التركي فؤاد اقطعي مقدما
حصيله جديده فقد ارتفع عدد القتلى من جراء
هذا الزلزال في تركيا الى
والجرحى الى
14,483
وايضا كشف او تحدث اوكتاي عن انه جرى
انقاذ حتى الان
7,840 شخصا من بين الانقاد وتحدث عن تطور
تطور
عمليات الاغاثه والانقاذي على الارض معنى
الان من بيروت لويس ميجال بوينو المتحدث
باسم الاتحاد الاوروبي في الشرق الاوسط
وشمال افريقيا مرحبا بك سيد لويس ميجال
بوينو بالنسبه للاتحاد الاوروبي تعهد
بتقديم المساعده
العاجله لكل من تركيا وسوريا كيف يترجم
هذا الامر في كلا البلدين بالنظر الى
الظروف في كلا البلدى
شكرا جزيلا مساء الخير وتحيه لك
والمشاهدين الكرام والتعازي لاشر الضحايا
في هذه الكارثه الكبيره التي
دمرت هذه المناطق في سوريا وتركيا واتمنى
الشفاء العاجل للمصابين وبالتبع الاتحاد
الاوروبي قدم حتى الان من خلال الاليه
لديها الاليه
والعاجله لدول لدول مثل تركيا دول ثالثه
ومن خلالها يعني
قدم على الاقل
تسعه عشر فرقا مكونه من يعني مثلا الرجال
الاطفاء وايضا قدمت مساعده انسانيه
طبيه عاجله هناك يعني بعد الفرق الاوروبيه
موجوده للارض يعني من مثلا اليونان او حتى
دول مختلفه في وسط اوروبا من خلال هذه
الاليه نحن نقدم وننسق مع سلطه البحريه
التركيه هذه هي العم
طبعا الوضع في سوريا يختلف لان هناك
صعوباتيه كثيره في هذه المناطق المتضرره
من
من سوريا ولكن رغم ذلك الاتحاد الاوروبي
كانت منذ سنوات
الدوليه الانسانيه لصالح الشعب السوري
فبالتالي هناك يعني في هذا المناطق
الشركاء في مجال الانسان للاتحاد الاوروبي
مدعومه من قبل الذين يقومون الان بتقديم
هذه المساعده وايضا بتقديم او بيقومون
بعمليات البحث
والانقاذ وذلك في في اوقات او في هذه
الاوقات السابقه في ظروف سابه للغايه ونحن
يعني سنركز ونركز الان مع الامم المتحده
يعني تنسيق هذه هي العمليات كابل الامكان
وطبعا يعني الامر بحاجه لمثابره بحاجه الى
المزيد من الاستاذه دائما المتحده وما هذه
المنظمات الخيريه ما نوع المساعدات التي
تستعدون
تقديمها لسيما نتحدث هنا
بالنسبه لاختلاف الظروف في كلا البلدين
بين تركيا وسوريا
هلا طبعا في سوريا اتت هذه الكارثه في
اسوا الاوقات نتحدث ملايين من السوريين
الذين يعيشون كنزيهين في هذه المناطق في
ظروف صعبه للغايه وبالاضافه لذلك اتت
بمنتصف الشتاء وهذه الظروف الجويه السابعه
التي لا تتوقف يعني الامثال الغسيله وما
الى ذلك فهذه المساعده تتكون او يعني هذه
المساعده خصوصا في مجال المياه ومجال
الصرف الصحي ومجال مثلا
المواد الغير الغذائيه الاساسيه للناس هي
المساعده العاجله التي التي يعني لدينا
نحن من خلال هذه الشركاء الانسانيين
والمنظمات الخيريه الان في تركيا يختلف
تماما يعني حدث الان عن فرق مختلفه مكونه
من اطباء وما الى ذلك لكن نتمنى باننا
سنتمكن من خلال الامم المتحده من خلال هذه
المنظمات الاخيريه في سوريا
من تقديم هذه المشاهده ايضا
واقول لك بان هناك تضامن كبير من قبل
الشعب الاوروبي باتجاه الشاب السوري
والشاب التركي كذلك
طيب ممكن ايصال هذه المساعدات ايضا بالنظر
الى ظروف العقوبات وان معبرا واحد فقط
يمكن ادخال عبره هذه المساعدات
دعوني يعني هناك نقطه لغايه اهميه هنا
اللي هي العقوبات العقوبات الاوروبيه
مستهدفه يعني لا نعاقب نحن في الاتحاد
الاوروبي المساعده
لم نقوم بذلك خلال سنوات الماضيه فكل
المساعدات الانسانيه
بعيده تماما عن اي كان من العقوبات
العقوبات لا تستهدف في مثل هذه المذابه
والنقطه الثانيه اللي هي نحن نقدم
مساعداتنا في سوريا في كل المناطق سواء
كان المناطق النظام ام لا
فهذا هو المطلوب اللي انا من من الاتحاد
الاوروبي شكرا جزيلا لك من بيروت لويس
ميجال بوانو المتحدث باسم الاتحاد
الاوروبي في الشرق الاوسط وشمال افريقيا
حدثنا من بيروت شكرا لك
اذا مشاهدينا نهايه حصادي هذه الليله
وصلنا اذا الى نهايه هذا هذا